c'est une marque bien connue des
téléspectateurs de tf1 qui fait son
retour à l'antenne après un retour raté
en 2015 une famille en or va revenir sur
les écrans cette fois ci avec camille
combal à la présentation on va jouer à
ça tous ensemble
un choix qui semble être devenu une
habitude après avoir placé l'animateur à
la tête de format déjà existants comme
danse avec les stars ou qui veut gagner
des millions chapeau au milieu de tout
ça si une famille en or existe depuis
des années 90 il avait fait un premier
grand retour sur tf1 avec christophe
dechavanne
un style singulier qui avait permis au
jeu de connaître une seconde jeunesse en
2017 c'est cyril hanouna qui réadapte et
ce jeu culte dans une version
remasterisée intitulé family battles est
comme une famille en or tant qu'on va
parler qu'anglais
reste à savoir comment camille combal va
s'approprier le format et trouver ses
repères dans ce jeu culte déjà très
marquée par plusieurs animateurs alors
le retour de la famille en or sur tf1
j'y crois ou j'y crois pas les palettes
en écosse
non seulement vous ne croyez pas mais en
plus il est choqué qu'est ce qui vous
arrive
si on prend des gants comprendre
jusqu'où ils vont aller et camille
combal
il passe son temps alors qui veut gagner
des millions
la famille en or bientôt c'est quoi
c'est l'académie des neuf le dire c'est
bien car je vais présenter n'y a pas de
[Musique]
comines format dans le monde des
secondaires on a besoin d'aller
rechercher encore et de faire une
resucée de la famille en or qui a été
arrêté on s'amuse échanges intenses
non moi je trouve que c'est une
excellente idée parce que ça fait rêver
les gens m'ont dit le contraire que je
vous aurais pas cru
oui bon c'était d'accord je suis
d'accord sur ces huit les boîtes ça
cartonne c'est un truc qui est revenu ça
cartonne voyage parle de ses mythes
aussi donc c'est bien aussi et et voilà
et camille combal c'est une excellente
idée parce qu'il faut quelqu'un qui est
proche des gens comme philippe risoli à
l'époque quand il faisait les jeux était
très proche des gens et il a pris un
carton
oui mais sauf que ce jeu là par amour si
jusqu aux gens que l'on croît m bernique
off c'est un jeu qui a du mal être
relancé à chaque fois vous aviez le
moderniser ils vont camille combal moi
je suis désolé camille il est excellent
on est tous d'accord pour dire ça mais
tu peux pas le mettre sur tous les
programmes sous prétexte que ce qu'il a
fait sur certains programmes et bankable
moi je suis désolé christophe dechavanne
pourquoi est ce qu'on fout à la poubelle
moi j'aime bien le voir christophe des
savanes ça me plairait de le revoir dans
une famille en or c'est un bon concept
est un concept ringard qui est très bon
parce que moi j'adore nation à la garde
et c'est très bon la famille en or mais
pas avec camille combal
laissez le tranquille il faut que tu
prennes les week-ends des fois aussi que
une vatan je pense que là c'est au delà
de sa simple hommes de concept une
famille en or ça repose sur
l'authenticité et la spontanéité des
candidats et on sait qu'aujourd'hui
quand une famille va sur un plateau il
ya pu y a plus rien de sa lente est
calculé pour faire le buzz on va sortir
toi là tu dis ça tu vas sortir ça donc
en fait le concept est faussée dès le
départ donc pour moi c'est un échec
assuré par rapport à ça un an et sur
camille pourquoi pas mais faut pas trop
le musée non plus un mais utilement non
mais moi je pense qu'on est toujours
vous savez on est on attend le point
d'orgue de la petite guéguerre enlevant
l'or le oui absolument absolument entrer
syrie mais précieuse avec les mots il
avait pas trop courir dessus
mytf1 est d'ailleurs le pied de la mieux
mettre à son ancien petit protégé aux
commandes d'un format que lui même a des
là en 2020 avec une émission so feelgood
très familial
tf1 dit pourquoi pas et pourquoi on va
pas lui [ __ ] camille en face pour voir
ce que ce qu'est ce que cas il peut en
faire parce que je suis sûr que camille
il va y va il va cartonner dans ce
programme j'en suis persuadé je vous
mets un billet sur la table corps